les choses vont mieux le monde est meilleur
juste parce qu'il n'y a pas de guerre ne
veut pas dire qu'il y a la paix il vient certains l'
appellent l'apocalypse il était une sorte de Dieu
pendant des milliers d'années il a
amassé des mutants pour prendre leurs pouvoirs
qu'il a toujours eu pour les polymères comme le  Four
Horsemen Eric ne les rejoignez pas quoi que
ce soit que vous pensez avoir vu en moi je l'ai
enterré avec ma famille ensemble nous allons
nettoyer la terre tout ce qu'ils ont
construit tombera ils l'ont pris présent
le monde a besoin des x-men que je suis  pas un héros les
étudiants vous admirent si je vais
enseigner quelque chose à vos enfants je vais
leur apprendre à se battre
haha ​​je n'ai pas peur d'eux j'ai besoin oh
c'est mon père
quoi jamais ma mère ouais je sais
pas  nous pouvons tous contrôler nos pouvoirs
alors ne pas
apocalypse signifie détruire ce monde
c'est nous tous contre un dieu et les
êtres les plus puissants de la terre
oubliez tout ce que vous pensez que vous
ne savez rien de tout cela
vous n'êtes plus étudiants je vais prendre
soin de quoi que ce soit de ce
bien que tu as été bu  sy nous avons eu un peu d'
aide pour
vous